Hello?
Ooh, welcome home, honey.
Come take a seat.
You must be starving.
Yeah, OK.
Ted, congratulations on your big win.
I didn't know if you'd be in the mood for meatloaf or lasagna,
so I made both.
Mom, what's wrong?
Why are you here?
What do you mean?
I mean, if you got something you need to say to me,
I'd appreciate it if you just went ahead and said it.
Oh, stop.
I just want to spend my last night in London with my son
and make sure everything's all right.
OK.
Well, thank you cooking dinner, both of them.
Oh, you're welcome.
[MUTED] you for not wanting to talk.
Excuse me?
Thank you for flying all the way here to come see me.
[MUTED] you for not telling me you were coming.
Thank you for all the small, silly little things
you did for me as a kid, you know,
like hiding notes in my lunchbox or putting
googly eyes on the fruit at the supermarket
just to make me laugh.
And [MUTED] you for not working on yourself or seeking
help after we lost dad and for not
talking to me about it either, just glossing
over the whole thing and acting like everything was all right.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know what to do, Ted.
So-- I pretended I was OK.
OK.
Well, thank you for the apology.
[MUTED] you for making me think I had to pretend, too.
All right.
I appreciate you sharing all this with me.
I just wish you hadn't carried it around for so long.
Yeah, OK.
And now, you're right, Ted, I do have something to say to you.
Your son misses you.
[SLOW MUSIC]
I know.
I miss him, too.
It's just like--
It's just like I'm scared.
if sometimes I get close to that little boy.
Oh, honey.
Why?
Because I know he's going to leave.
[SLOW MUSIC]
Oh, well.
Come on.
No.
All right.
That is the thing about being a parent.
Sometimes you lose.
And sometimes you win.
But most of the time, you just tie.
All we can do is keep playing.
[SLOW MUSIC]
Thank you.
[MUTED] you.
[GIGGLES]